what's up babe listen the only tickets I
have left are May 6th in Ithaca New York
the State Theater of Ithaca May 6 we got
a few tickets left and then uh September
22nd New York City Radio City is sold
out so we've added September 23rd the
theater on Madison Square Garden in New
York City those tickets are almost sold
out too so go get your tickets but
everywhere else Buffalo Albany Newport
Rhode Island it's all sold out
christycomedy.com for Ticky wikis
all right guys here we go tonight I'm in
Bangor Maine tonight at the Cross
Insurance Center this weekend we're at
the Wang theater for three in Boston uh
next week we're in West Valley Utah and
the Bellco Theater in Denver Colorado uh
May 19th we're doing Texas Arlington
Texas Austin Texas at the Moody Center
Sugar Land Texas at the Smart Center uh
Financial Center May 21st June we're in
Columbus Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis
Des Moines Kansas City uh July we got
National Indianapolis and St Louis
they're all on sale right now at
impracticaljokerslive.com this tour has
been so much fun we always have
different openers and surprise guests
get your tickets uh tonight is the half
season finale of impractical jokes on
TBS at 10 o'clock uh with Blake Anderson
is the guest star of Workaholics Fame
and other stuff so check that out and go
to get shipfaced cruise.com to see with
uh what we are doing with Eric Andre
very soon I love you all and thank you
so much for that
bye March
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
you know I like my chicken fried a cold
beer on a Friday night a pair of jeans
that fit just right
[Music]
oh
hey babe how are you let me first of all
also I miss you I miss you I'm talking
to you baby
I miss you and I miss you
um like the deserts miss the rain
let me tell you something let me tell
you something first of all babe I need
to make this comment immediately you've
lost weight it's noticeable it's getting
noticeable now yeah all right and do you
feel do you feel good is the only
question that matters because you can
have a million people tell you you look
good but is how does little Sal feel not
good you know not good yeah sometimes
when I get up too fast I feel I'm gonna
faint yeah but that's but that's not um
that's that's that's not from the diet
that's from the uh I like my chicken
fried you do like a chicken fried but
cold beer on Friday night uh you know I
know because of the special
oh I'm putting in I'm putting in a
little can we stop putting in work I'm
just eating better can we say where
we're doing the special yellow is it on
the down low well like our sexuality
yeah a legendary and if you have a
problem with it take it up with Bloom
Cafe uh so it it it's shifted around a
lot and it was October then it was
December 1st and it was November 2nd now
it might be October 13 to 20th I'm
waiting for the theater to come back to
me wow near your birthday yes yeah right
around there little birthday celebration
so I'm hoping to do it the 13th if not
the 20th if not the second and if the
theater I wanted isn't available I gotta
I gotta shift gear but those will be the
dates are you gonna do it in the
metropolitan area I was not I was
actually going to do it in another
Metropolitan City not too far from here
let's talk about that yeah does the
metropolitan area only apply to the
tri-state area of New York New Jersey
and Connecticut or their metropolitan
areas in different places absolutely so
there are metropolitan areas all over
the place but when you say the
metropolitan area I think the
metropolitan area that you were existing
in is the contextual reference that
you're making so you could be in the
metropolitan area of Bangladesh it's
just you're it it depends on what
Metropolis you're talking about I think
if you say I was in you know Bangladesh
in their greater metropolitan area I
know where you are if you tell me are
you going to do it in the metropolitan
in the metropolitan area right I think
you're saying that this is this area I'm
gonna do it in a metropolitan area right
yeah but can I are there other Tri-State
areas then like can Pennsylvania West
Virginia and Virginia be a tri-state
area or it's just New York New Jersey
Connecticut the only Tri-State I think
we coined that but I don't know
it's a question for Yolanda Vega who'll
be our next guest oh my God next week
guys we have you know is that was that
check by security
I'm just gonna put on my I'm going to
get my glasses because I hear him hit
the keys I have my glasses and I have to
have my glances and my shoes so I have
them
to The Jerky Boys shout out to jerky I
mean they came and they dominate they
were the thing they were the things I'm
a little older than you but when when
they came out I believe I was in high
school so when did it hit you the Jerky
Boys are a craze The Jerky Boys
for the Young The Jerky Boys are the
they were the original are you garbage
I did taste buds and it was a home run
babe they are well they're home run
hitters they love all your garbage why
don't you guys explain what what the
Jerky Boys was so an American Comedy act
from Queens New York two guys two guys
um Johnny and kume uh
um
um they were well Sal you can explain it
better because I feel like it hit I was
still a bit young I heard it later but
you heard it as it was happening I heard
it in like freshman year high school I
think and what happened was these two
guys made prank phone calls new glasses
by the way old
but but but kind of Revisited and kind
of they're feeling new on your face
because that those are those types of
glasses where I kind of feel like you
couldn't you put those on and it's like
of course I'm gonna say something oh
yeah yeah because they're they're very
very very they're um make a point oh oh
well I like not trying to make a point
but but no no no but but but it says I
think it's because I'm not wearing like
what I normally would wear like my hair
or just look back because I was just
running and um sweaty and it was normal
if I had a hat and stuff maybe it might
blend in more I think they're right in
your face here's the energy if you were
walking past me if I was in the car and
you're walking past me I would say I
would say to this guy I'd look at him
whoever in the car and I'd say even
though that guy has on those glasses I
like that guy okay that's what it is
because we've had this during Dynamic
before when I wore a Wool Cap right yeah
I'm not trying to yeah I'm not trying to
improve any point here right this is uh
because I think because I'm in this kind
of outfit it's not it's not jiving maybe
well and that's okay because what you
just said just implied that if it was
another guy yeah you don't like the
glasses
you're saying I wouldn't hit a guy I
wouldn't hit that guy I like it I like
uh and by the way I just want I know you
can't see but the sound does have shorts
on and so in an effort to be in
solidarity with my friend and teammate
here I've pulled my pants up a little
bit to show some might still have a lack
of leg hair like I do yeah
yeah you are fishing is not great
I found out late in life I had two
astigmatisms my whole life anything
about it didn't even know what that
meant you know what it means my eyes and
like football I swear to Christ
they stay like Stewie heads or something
and I can't see far and it's getting
worse and the reason I don't wear those
a lot anymore there are a few
prescriptions ago okay a couple ago and
so I just feel like I think the rumor is
that if you do that you could be to your
detriment I don't know
to be honest with you do you like JFK's
I see a little bit better with these I
might have a stigmatism too you'd never
go to the doctor do you have
prescription glasses no but you know
what I have to go get a vision test
because I was told actually Yesterday by
the DMV or I got the mail yesterday if I
don't get my vision sent into the DMV my
license will be suspended no I have not
submitted a vision test in over 10 years
and they have had enough really the
state of New York said we will suspend
your license if you do not submit it so
what's the clock I think I think I I
think literally my license might be
actively suspended whoa let me do the
test for you right now then
Eurovision
don't change that thought don't change
that dial uh do you guys want to see
different eye shapes here yeah I mean
what else what else are we going to
masturbate oh but those are
those are there are balls like oh
they're on their face though like I
don't have I don't have football shaped
eye
eyes I have football shaped i ball well
it says the most common shape is almond
almonds which looks like a football I
like almond shaped eyes better than
football shaped eyes even if they both
imply the same thing that you can't see
yeah but I do like I would like to I'd
rather say my eyeballs are almond shaped
than football I love an almond-shaped
eye on the exterior hey guys love is it
almond almond is the L Sil silent it's
like salmon
almond right almond if you say almond
that's wrong it's not almond right it's
not salmon it's not salmon it should be
it should be who made that up yeah it's
stupid and how come you could say salmon
but then it's salmonella but it's both
s-a-l-m-o-n now why isn't almond spelled
a-m-o-n-d almond
oh she almond oh she is saying almond
almond wow
it's almond
um uh did you know it was almond oh hit
the slow button let us say it's slow
yeah
oh man that's like what's the cat it's
okay I think she's like almond speaking
of slow what's your um what's your
opinion on the new Down syndrome Barbie
I saw that I saw that I think it's
terrific me too yeah
thank you Sam Street what did he say he
just put the link and he put sales are
slow I mean that's a 10 out of 10 tweets
yeah that's to see that now now I think
it's fantastic I think I think it kind
of looks like that it has it looks like
Brendan sagalo a little bit in the face
a little bit
um I it's not is that what is that
vibration sorry that's
I don't know what that was is that birth
control uh
let's see right now uh weather weather
advisory
I don't know what that was I don't know
I must have missed the call hold on I
did miss it it's Dexter is do you want
to call him back no see it did he murder
someone
sounds represented by Dexter from the
crime show on Showtime did you let me
ask you a question
no you know what I'm gonna finally say
no okay
almond
can I post something toward you yes that
that uh yes you're not a murderer but
tell me when you watch it allegedly
when you watch it didn't it seem I'd be
murdering that yeah yeah sorry
that's yes yes
that's right yes
So speaking of that protection uh didn't
it seem cool when he taped the whole
room in plastic yeah like that's I still
like I don't want to kill anybody but
like to take the whole room in plastic
and then kill somebody I gotta be honest
with you the fact that he did all of
that and then still had the energy to go
through with the kill because for me it
would be taping the whole room like when
I watch a guy paint I can't believe
there's not a separate team that does
all the taping and plastic you know
Plastics off and then they paint I'm
like the amount of energy it would take
to to plaster that whole room and then
you want to murder someone yeah I'd be
like you know what I'm over it a hundred
you know in the directors cut there's
like 14 extra minutes of the tape full
and putting it back yeah and
then he's getting heated yeah and that's
why he's ready for the kids have you
watched the new Dexter because I'm only
a fan of the old deck so I haven't seen
one second of the new I haven't seen any
new and I didn't watch like the last
season or so of the old because I heard
it tanked but I really should have and I
would have and I'm a big fan of Michael
C Hall and he was almost a guest on
Impractical Jokers last season really
and so I would love to have them yeah
that would be fun if you had them on and
he taped you guys up again
he killed one of you yeah my my old bar
we used to have this Thursday night
party called karaoke killed the cat Okay
and uh I met them on on the cruise you
did you did and it was it would always
be this crazy dance party like people
would stage dive it would be packed out
it was a big big party right and every
so often they would throw a theme what
was booty okay and everyone everyone had
to wear tight tight short short booty
shorts even the guys uh one time we did
um uh there was another one and then one
time we did Carrie Okie okay which was
Carrie the movie which was the bucket of
blood wow so I I that's cool yeah so
what I did was uh my at the time I I was
just I think managing the place but I
asked the owner I was like can can you
let me have this I mean do this and they
said okay it's very cool we taped the
entire bar and restaurant up like Dexter
fully the entire thing sheets of plastic
everywhere a whole place in plastic and
then everyone came in was in the plastic
and we just handed out Buckets of Blood
the whole night people just throwing
Buckets of Blood on you how long did it
take it was it was three four hours
three four hours to play I will pimp
remind me I will send you the picture
later of of the party I have everyone
I'm covered in blood you open my eyes
all you see is eyeballs and red here's
the thing about you Sal is you have fun
and you live life I don't I know that
it's hard for us as people as we go
through this journey we're getting
pulled in a million directions but just
as an outsider looking in you as a 45
year old biological male I assume yes
yeah that that you have lived a great
life you literally have put in since
your adulthood let's say 25 years and
have more fun and have done more things
than most people have done in a lifetime
so you shouldn't ever regret anything in
your life I don't think from an outside
perspective looking in because you have
the these these things that you've done
the the blood parties the the the
the Blood Part the Halloween parades the
the the the the the the the
thing you were a part of where like you
would get shot with a water gun like
this that's the thing the magic shows
you've went to the street was all these
things are things people say they see
and they say I want to do that and they
never do but you actually do so you
don't ever lose sight of that if you
have thank you and now you've
participated in a bunch of those I have
participated in a couple of them and
then I have stopped doing them and I
regret that and I regret that because
because I sometimes sit here and even
though people will say oh he's so cool
comedy and blah blah blah I don't feel
like I do enough outside of it and I
sometimes I feel like man my life can be
mundane and it's because I'm not
actively searching for these things that
you're just like I'm gonna do it like
you're you know like you don't let
things stop you which I which I which is
um
admirable well I appreciate that yeah
lately I don't contagious I want to get
whatever I want to get contagious I have
what she's having I have what she's like
Harry Met Sally you know you know what
that reference is oh yeah when she has
an orgasm because sometimes with pop
culture I'm Italian I know because my
mom used to watch Harry Met Sally on
repeat and drink white zinfandel and cry
okay yeah yeah divorce okay yeah you
know I did I tell you I never saw
Sleepless in Seattle because when I was
in high school my teenage girlfriend
cheated on me I went to a on a date to
see it with a guy and I decided to never
want to never do it you can't do it I
can't do it now right
that was the day you died
dude now I don't watch it just for the
fun of it but like for the streak but
I'd say for the first few years I was
like I can't watch that yeah you can't
walk that's interesting isn't it funny
too how like just through life like like
because it's all chemicals like you
could be so
um it would hurt you so much you were so
in love with this person or or so hurt
by them that at a moment in time you
couldn't even watch a movie that they
watch where now if they were having sex
in front of you would step over them you
wouldn't it wouldn't care at all I
wouldn't care she could be having sex
with Tom Hanks it doesn't matter that
would be I would stop for that yeah that
that actually that would be cool thanks
yeah forget it yes what did you take on
Chet Hanks we talked about him before
right I want to play him in the movie
you got his life good yes did you ever
say that before is that the first time
the first time I ever said that I think
you could play him in a movie yeah I
want to I want you kind of looking like
each other a little bit a little bit I
mean he's got a rocking hotbod but yeah
but but but a little testosterone a
little
I'm talking like Matthew McConaughey too
he also looks like a skinhead he does he
lost he he goes anywhere from Matthew
McConaughey to a convicted Puerto Rican
fellow he goes he goes all on that yeah
yeah and I wonder the real question
should be Sal yeah the real question we
should be asking here on hey babe is
what is Tom Hanks think of Chad Hanks
don't worry about what I think about
Jeff what is Tom Hanks think of Chad
Hanks is the question right because he
has the other son Colin that looks like
him yeah and who's following his
footsteps yes here's what I do here's
what I'd say here's what I'd say if I
had to guess yeah if I had to put it
I would think that Chen Hanks gets along
better with Mom
that's what I if I had to guess Rita
Wilson is that her name it's Rita Wilson
Chad Hank's mom yeah Rita Wilson is more
like he's misunderstood he's a rebel and
I think she likes it I think Tom is like
Chet needs to get his
together like Colin you're not a
cheetah yeah chat is short for anything
chat Chatham
Tom says you know what Chet I can't have
you singing reggae and making believe
your different ethnicities I'm already
I'm already you know being accused of
being on Epstein's Island and a Greek
pedophile I don't need this is he
really so that was the big rumor with
covet no no Tom by the way none of the
It's gotta suck for the people on who
are on that Epstein's Vlog that went
over just for like like literally like I
was I was hired to Garden but it's like
well now guess what Esteban you're on
the list right right pedophile right you
just made the list you just made the
list yeah everybody who's over there is
on the list everyone he made this it was
a lock yeah so the list is comprised of
everyone who's ever been over there so
and that's the thing the internet will
run wild with certain names like also
Epstein some of them definitely went
over there to bang 13 year olds I
believe that but a lot of those people
are like they're just friends with a
billionaire that went on his private jet
as you all would do right as any of us
would have done if we didn't know
anything we would hey babe we would have
been on that plane yeah it
copped over for two nights I had a
little bit of the crew day today and I
went home I didn't touch anybody I had
it he was on hey babe that on the list
yeah we did he did taste buds too we
just knocked it all out yeah we just we
deleted those apps the law steps they'll
be available on the patreon on the
patreon yeah could you imagine that what
was the island what is that it's not
called Epstein's Island it's called like
little Saint James that's who you should
name our patreon little CJ we'll just
get people interested you guys see the
the teenagers who took a boat out to it
like how do you get there
oh it's like
what is it like Bermuda or something
like that
why is that news because they're not
it's private it's a funny video yeah
it's Private Island that's for sale oh
it's private so nobody's out there by
that island now well
wrote for a studio
really yeah he wants to buy an island
for a studio what about his studio now
it's a great bit yeah it's a great bit
that's a tax write-off how much
because we could do a GoFundMe right now
and do it yeah we could do a GoFundMe
and and we beat him to the punch that's
our new studio how about that 55 schmill
160 Acres that's money or 65 hectares
with three beaches not bad it's about 17
mil a beach it looks the perfect place
for DeRosa to retire
there is a way though there is a way
though to restore Epstein's Island and
bring it back to like kind of wipe the
stain off like if we bought it we would
bring back you got to make it right
again yes literally wipe off the stains
on we would have you know we could be
you know instead of having prince Andrew
we have Prince Paul who's going to be
who's a guest on upcoming taste buds
taste buds yes you know um you know we
don't have we need to hire a marketing
team yeah and we need to remarket it we
need to that's the island
oh my God that whole thing is 55 million
dollars
yeah okay I don't know seems steep yeah
yeah because really you're in your house
yeah you know like you're not like
here's the thing let me be honest with
you I just want to talk to you for a
second about travel and then I would
like talk to you for a minute about
intermittent fasting but before I like
talk to you about traveling sure um
I okay now
we can debate this we people can get
angry you can drive your car for Cliff
fine
I want to say to you though that in the
United States where we live in the
unless
yeah United States
I kind of feel like
if we're going to travel if you're going
to travel outside our country and take a
plane ride to go just sit on a beach
anywhere else in the world isn't worth
it when we can just go in our own
country to Florida or Southern
California or some of the other
beautiful beaches in the Gulf of Mexico
we can go to those beaches and yes I
know that maybe you know the sand in
Indonesia or somewhere is a little bit
better and the white but I think at the
end of the day it's the ocean and it's a
beach and and you can't tell me that
sitting at the breakers in West Palm
Beach Florida is that much is any it it
is worse is that much worse than sitting
at the Four Seasons in Polynesia okay
well if you want to travel I'm sorry let
me finish if you want to travel to
another place travel to see things that
America doesn't have like ancient
history and and things from from 2000
years ago that's that's just the point
I'm trying to make and I will take time
for debate right now do you uh do you
see what do you say do you what you do
like if you were in the uh if you were
in the parliament you would you do with
your time you seed your time what did
you do with your time I conceded my time
I could see my time okay do you conceit
it I could I've conceited Chrissy
conceded I don't disagree per se I I
think it's silly to go far far far far
far far far if you're gonna have the
same exact experience I will say that
there are places outside of the United
States that do blow the beaches the sand
and the water we have away okay blow
them away balls are blown off when you
see it and if you I mean look I don't
think you need to go to Indonesia and do
like a 20-hour flight if you're just
gonna go on the beach but there is
something to the seclusion
of an island as well it's not just you
know you're at the Four Seasons and
you're on the water on the Sands kind of
white and it's and there's the ocean's
kind of blue and you look up and there's
the building there and it's the
highway right there there's something to
going to I was in lizard Island in
Australia lizzo island lizard but lizzo
yeah I mean
that's beautiful you ready for this when
we buy Epstein's Island that's the
inaugural performer lizzo it's lizzo's
Island for the weekend that's who's
gonna change it for us that's gonna
bring everybody in there ain't nobody
that don't love lizzo lizzo the old by
the way the ultimate goal the putting
the energy out there right now is to get
Liz on hey babe then we have the show
if lizzo ever comes on then that's the
swans that's it that's the swan we're
gonna need a buyout from hellofresh for
that and we're gonna do that
so lizzo
of watching and we know that you are uh
give us a give us a little ring of ding
and uh let me know when you oh my God is
she in a Hershey's chocolate that's
amazing I love that that's amazing uh
lizzo the the couch is open for you yes
uh um so
um um
check this out you gotta check it you
gotta fly in on a helicopter or a boat
where's Lizard Island by the way I'm
sorry uh it's in the great Court of the
coral reef Australia yeah right yeah
might so which I'm not going to but I've
rescheduled yeah I'm I'm in the process
of rescheduling I'm sorry I just got
upset nervous about coming I didn't want
to be on the side of my family I was
going through a little bit of mental
health stuff so I I appreciate um all
the fans of Australia supporting me I
hope you're doing the ones that left
I'll see you later I apologize if you
left but I I mean you it's all you
can do I'm sorry later for you yeah it's
all you can do you can't do that yeah
yeah so here's the thing uh it was so
the only there's only one small Resort
on the island and there's no other
inhabitants okay and in order to live on
the island you have to work at that
Resort that's that's it and there's like
30 beach bungalows okay and so the whole
Island's like 100 people on this island
only and you have your own Bungalow and
you get your own boat and the whole
island is all Beach and you could just
take the boat out every day they they
literally give you a cooler they stack
it with wine drinks food and you just
leave and you just take a little uh
motor boat to the beaches on your own
and it's completely quiet and it's it's
it's it's unreal like this the sky is
bright orange and pink you watch the
sunsets it's quiet it looks like a
Corona camera it's just like it's
different than Florida you know what I
mean so in that respect I get it because
it's like it's a whole experience in
another respect if you're gonna go to a
beach area where there's a completely
different culture and maybe participate
in that culture maybe but for the for
the majority I agree with you that it
it's right because we could also go to
Hawaii yeah but check this though I
would still go three hours or three and
a half hours to like the Caribbean and
as opposed to three hours to Florida I
would still do that because it's same
travel really right and I think the
Caribbean is better than Florida then
okay you're not really you're not really
spending any more time to get there well
I'm saying that to say that I just came
from Sicily Sicily yeah and well that's
different though right in the
Mediterranean well well that well that
that this is my point is that I feel
like the trip to Sicily specifically
taramina Sicily at the San Domenico
Palace Hotel which is where they filmed
the show White Lotus was the you know
when people go on vacation and they say
I feel so relaxed I feel so recharged
I've never felt that truly once in my
life never once in my life have I ever
felt that I've always felt like I'm more
exhausted especially with traveling with
the children it's it's just I'm I I'm
worse than I when I left because I'm so
tired this time I genuinely feel relaxed
and recharged from just spending four
days over there I just feel like I was
in a place that you know was by the I we
saw the Mediterranean team but also the
ionian sea we were up in these mountains
and off this beautiful yeah this was the
view uh is this my yeah this one well
that's not this is not taramina but
that's one of those that's one of those
yeah
um
so uh I don't know that I posted any of
the pictures of uh that's why that's you
you standing next to that yeah
so there's a point is there anything
there that holds that up so okay so what
about erosion so just real quick this is
called the valedict this is the valley
of temples the a lot of people think
that you know Greeks the Greek temples
and Greek is it was first done in Greece
these temples were put up by the Greeks
by but before Greece became Greece
Greece was only Greece as we know it and
all the history of Greece was United by
Alexander the Great these temples were
put up in Sicily about a hundred years
before Alexander the Great so so this
was a this is a pre-unified Greece they
were already doing this and they still
stand up today like that they they were
found like that they sound like a
craftsmanship good craftsmanship that
was this is you know 500 BC they put
this up it's unbelievable the irrigation
systems and all the things they did it
it really is if you have a chance to go
to Sicily I did not go to the mainland
Italy and I'm sure it's beautiful in as
much history but Sicily I will say this
and taramina I had a great time in
Palermo I did like Palermo but there was
a City Vibe more it was like in New York
City but with a lot older stuff and it
was beautiful to see but taramina this
is this is syracusa and that is um that
was uh Shaka this is the town of Shaka
which is which is beautiful as well just
like an old it's like a town from a
movie like it's almost like all you saw
like you we went we were in the town at
9 30 as or 10 a.m as things were opening
it's like you see like you saw like oh
like opening opening that yeah old man
walking out of like you know their their
little apartments little kids going to
school you know people going you know
bonjour no you know like that like it
felt like a movie like people were
saying you to each other yes okay
yes yeah
yeah they were saying every time
somebody would say bonjourno I would go
DiGiorno as a little joke and they must
have loved it yeah and they would just
look at me it looks amazing I've only
been to Italy once I went to the Amalfi
Coast which is similar it's beautiful
similar Vibes right I felt the exactly I
thought it was magical yes the second we
arrived to the hotel and opened our room
to our door and went on a Terrace and we
looked out of that view we just looked I
was like
it takes your breath away rocket money
and burning up your subscriptions rocket
money baby we like it used to be true
Bill yes but now it's basically like if
you're the person which I'm the person
who I always forget that I'm subscribed
to different things and I'm paying money
every month that I even forget about
what rocket money does is you literally
they will cancel your unwanted
subscriptions for you that's what this
place does simple yet genius no one's
done it that I know of no and you just
download it and they they get all
everything you and then you can cancel
with just a button because you know what
you know what's up with that stuff yes
you got to write a letter you gotta
write an email you got to find a little
Link at the bottom of the website page
and you gotta subscribe it's just it's
rocket money does all that does all that
for you you and they they will get you
money they will get you hundreds of
dollars back into your account that you
did not even know you were giving away
most Americans spend around 80 bucks a
month on subscriptions but the actual
total is closer to 200 they think they
spend 80 the actual 200 bucks on
subscriptions 80 yeah they have
subscriptions they forgot about like the
stars app you know you got the Stars app
you watch one show and then you got you
know the free gaming trial you never use
and then boom next thing happens all the
time happens all the time you do uh you
do it uh what do you call that a a a a
introductory like a freeway yes but then
it's never free yeah and then by the way
they raise the prices don't think I
didn't see that Netflix off yes y'all
raising yeah so stop throwing your money
away cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe rocketmoney.com
hey babe it it did and and it I just
felt like truly like it that's why I
brought this up to say if I was gonna
travel you know it's eight hour flight
whatever I I'm happy that we didn't sit
on it we stayed in one of the places we
stayed in it was like kind of like a
resort on the beach and we only sat on
the beach at night as we were having
dinner but I I feel like just it's one
of those things like you know like when
you when you hear and again I've never
experienced this you might have already
the relax recharging but also I fell in
love with the people I've never felt
that but I did fall in love with this
just the Sicilian people they were just
amazing now they may have been cursing
me out and be like the stupid
American I'm ripping them off but you
know I charge them ten dollars for his
gelato sandwich whatever it was but I
didn't if they did if that was the truth
I didn't feel it it doesn't come across
and I felt like I fell in love with the
people the only thing I will say and
this is a blanket statement this is a
blanket statement nothing to do with
Sicily this is a blanken statement for
and it might just be the way I feel but
just for not customer service but it's a
blanket too it's a not a Chenille throw
statement we are I am not I am I am
saying this overall it might just be the
way I feel some people might like to be
pampered and some people might like it
but I it stresses me out I do not like
where as soon as I get out of the car to
my hotel people from the hotel are are
asking to take my bags I do not want you
to touch I hate it I believe it
to be not genuine and I believe all you
are doing is hating take it because then
I have to tip you and I have told that
people at the hotel multiple times I do
not want you to take my back I have a
book bag and a small Karen I will take
it to the room myself and you insisted
and then and then only because of the
money and then the last time and you
know I walked out of the hotel I said I
am not giving you my bags I just want to
get in the car please and you look
defended at me and then of course I felt
bad and I wired you fifty dollars
account and you got twice the money for
me and it is all a scam I just want to
hold my own bags please yeah it
sounds like you had the most relaxing
time yes yes you said that you don't
understand that is how I feel every time
because I just have the little roller
bag or whatever I have but it doesn't
matter I can get it to my room because
then they take it sometimes then you get
to the room sometimes it doesn't get
into like 20 minutes no I don't need it
at all I don't I know you have to make
tips but I I I'm on vacation I paid a
lot of money stay in this hotel leave me
alone yeah so what I preemptively tried
to do yeah if the last hotel we stayed
is as soon as I checked in like I got
that you got it they were like do you
need any help with the bags and I said
no I don't I said and I won't add off
for the remainder of this day I said if
I need help with anything I'm going to
call you I said but please for the
remainder of my stay please just if I
need anything I will call you I don't
need turndown service and I don't need
anything all I need is if I I will call
you and ask you something and the guy
the guy said of course he said 100 no
problem he said you know what he said
that's in there pray I pray for you I
pray with you pray with me is that what
that is that's right Prego but they say
it like of course like like if you said
um if I was like Hey can I have uh you
know a lemon challenge
but it says fire that means Prego but
Prego means it's like it means please
but it also means I pray but it means
technically it means we ask them it
means I I um like I I pray I pray with
you I pray you okay like please I pray
you
yeah to pray is the first version to
pray yeah I pray yeah that's what it
kind of means but but um but so pink
just pulled up one to five dollars per
bag for the porters now I understand
that's a big Range Five is five hundred
percent more money yes if you have five
bags you can give them a five or a 25
yeah and listen I get people I have to
make money I get it but I just I almost
the the let me take your bags please
thing it's because I just know that
there's it's not genuine I'd rather you
almost say can I like I would actually
not feel even a cent my blood pressure
wouldn't go up one point if you just
came up to me if you reported and you
said can I take your bags and you give
me five dollars I'd like 100 okay here's
give it five I'll give you ten here's my
ish number one I always forget so like I
have 20 bucks I have 20s on me only and
look I mean not that I I oh I I've over
tipped my entire life I've worked in a
service industry right right but like
sometimes it's just like it's like all
right you take like a backpack and a bag
and you walk next to me right and then
we get there right and I look and I got
like 20 now I mean twenty dollars but
the other thing is I know what you mean
because I would like I would like to
pull up and they go
uh would you like help with the bags and
I could say no thank you but they don't
they actually go they just come right up
and they start getting out of the back I
don't like it
I don't like it at all yeah I don't need
it I don't like it I tip my tipping
strategy is I tip you know drivers I tip
the the the cleaning staff you know you
ten dollars a day if it's a nice hotel
twenty dollars a day I always hear them
always do the bag guys I understand
they're working too but for me it's like
pool the tips I don't need you I I'm
tipping other people because I don't
want to clean my room and I'm not
driving the Uber right so you that's
where you get a tip the bags I'll do it
I I have zero problems I don't want you
to do it I mean if I roll up and I'm
with like a ton of people like I brought
my family in this 10 bags and then that
by all means I can't wait but I'll tell
you if I say no please don't touch my
bags then then I look like the dick yeah
the problem becomes I don't like when
they ask when it's just one roller bag
for myself I'm like I don't need I feel
weird it feels it actually also feels
weird right like yeah you take it I'll
watch you take it over like the problem
the ish becomes to at least in America
Sicily you know nobody really a couple
of people said hi to me but and you
let's you know let's be honest I'm I'm
comfortable with who I am but you're
gonna have to deal with I have to deal
with them on a smaller scale but you
have deals on a bigger scale the problem
what happens is in this celeb life
smaller version for me but still there
is what happens in society I think is if
you get recognized and you don't over
tip then what happens is is they go back
and say so and so was a cheap phone when
it's like hey when I you know am I
asking uh Jeff Bezos for money just
because he has money just because I make
money and do that doesn't mean you
deserve it for nothing I'll give you
what I'll give you a percentage of the
tip for the work that you do that's how
I want to be treated so that's how I'll
treat you yeah but in in today's society
it becomes give me everything even if
I'm not working for and I don't like it
at all yeah because I didn't I don't
feel I'm that way I always over tip for
goodness well why over tip anyway if you
recognize me just know right then and
there you're getting 30 more because I
don't want you to talk about me
even though they listen this podcast
sponsored by betterhelp as it always is
this episode brought to you by
betterhelp we love it we love better
help we are both users of it we talk to
the therapists they help us through
stuff mental health is very important
and better help you don't have to go
anywhere you can do it from the comfort
of your own home all done online with
professional therapists and you know
therapy isn't always associated with
just strictly oh I gotta go uh you know
I have this issue or this thing you
could also
go to therapy to find out more about
yourself and who you are yes you don't
take the time in your normal life to
stop down and actually reflect and talk
out loud about things that are going on
in your mind and that's how you process
those things and and find out more about
your actual true self because getting to
know yourself it can be a lifelong
process so you know we're always growing
and changing so the who you were five
years ago you mean it may not know that
person you may need therapy to get to
know that person a hundred and therapy
is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding right
so better help connect you with a
licensed therapist who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited for your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
betterhelp.com hey babe today get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash hey babe 10 off your
first month discover your potential with
better help
did you guys this is a new thing
everyone's dealing with the tip flation
they're even asking for attention
counters I know because because they
well what they do now is the now listen
that's so weird it's like you pay
someone you literally put something on
the counter they ring it up they turn it
they turn the thing and you like swipe
your card there's no extra service done
no and it says tip 15 20 25 custom or no
thanks and you're just like um now
listen if it's a matter of five bucks
where a five bucks might help someone
might be a bigger percentage of their
income to give them five dollars and it
would be for mine and I can afford to
give it I'll gladly give it gladly give
it no problem the place where you're
supposed to tip I always tip yeah but
I'm talking about this thing this thing
comes up now everywhere everywhere it
when it when there's no tips
and it comes up comes up yeah it's weird
they're trying to push us more towards
communism that's why um what's the
weirdest person you've ever tipped like
what's the weirdest thing you ever
tipped for oh the weirdest thing
I've ever I tell you that I was big I
just left some I left some big
tips
some big I remember the big tips because
it's like I you know who I tip the most
I tip by far the most The Comedy Club
Green Room waitress she gets paid them
or he gets paid or they get paid the
most I over tip because I know here's
the thing is because I know that they
probably know what I got paid so I you
have to like serve it around they get
usually the biggest tip I I for me I I
do you know what you usually do I I know
what I usually tip oh you actually put a
number like a percentage you go off a
percentage no I just tip the same exact
thing every time no matter if I get
anything or don't get anything
minus minus based off mine is on a
sliding scale based off what I made that
weekend I I always ask the wait waiter
waitress are you with me the whole week
and if they say yes if they say no I tip
them on what I am going to make that
night a percentage of that same yeah
well I just but it's always good they're
always thinking I just do it Flappy but
I do say like are you with me I'll get
you yeah before I leave this weekend
yeah but I think who's the weirdest
person I've tipped
for me it's like the garbage men so they
take everything oh I tip them you have
to on Staten Island I I those guys get
those guys get hooked up yeah yeah my
dad then they take my recycling even on
garbage they do it they'll take
everything if I put literally if I put
one of my kids out there they put her in
the truck I'll also take a drug
dealer I'll tip a drug dealer if they
came a long way okay
I don't know the drug dealing Community
what the um what you're supposed to do
I just don't know that world yeah I
would probably tip like a weed dealer
but I wouldn't know if I would tip like
a heroin deal how about this my dad
guess what you know who my dad tips
which I think is very strange and he's
the only one on the plane whoever does
it flight attendants my dad will tip his
flight attendant I never heard of that
in my life he does it
well this could get interesting
that's the name of the episode false
alarm they can't so what you just heard
was a uh the where we record this
podcast they uh the fire alarm just went
off and then someone came over the radio
and said uh this is the fire director
that was a false alarm but I think what
happened was Yolanda Vegas here
she sets them off she walks in she's
like it's your London and then all the
alarms went off I can't tell you how
excited I am that she's gonna be now you
wore your best outfit yeah
[Laughter]
the word Queen gets thrown around a lot
right it does Queen yes queen queen
queen England Queen's just died yeah
Queen of Hearts but she is the queen if
you're from New York she is uh she is
one of our fearless leaders she
literally Yolanda Vega is one of her
she's all person that if I saw her in
the street I'd yell her name I would do
I would I would really Act a Fool she's
someone who could I could maybe witness
her shiv somebody like Dexter or
something like that and then I wouldn't
report her no
She's Gotta pass I wouldn't do it yeah
she's like a Derek Jeter I have like
Derek Jeter has committed a crime to be
like don't worry about it oh my god did
you see that see that autograph I was
always wondering because someone gave me
that on her you did right who gave me
that Yolanda Vega someone gave me that
on her behalf and I always wondered like
you never know if it came from the
source directly but there was another
autograph online it matched the
handwriting so I brought it today for
authentication purposes here it is look
yeah there it is that exact one wow but
she signed it now she was NBC what is
the Lotto on was it on every channel was
it on only one specific Channel it was
it was it was only on ABC so she worked
for ABC
do they still do the lotto ever like
because I feel like the lotto kind of
took a dip when Yolanda left yeah I
personally stopped playing once Vega
left I want to ask her if she ever has
beef with the New York State Lotto guy
the cardboard if they have beef oh yeah
he he doesn't announce the numbers but
he's the figurehead right he he does
that whole thing where it's like
foreign
the New York State Lottery is now
70 million dollars yeah they do that so
they could just record him once and he
doesn't have to say Do they still do
that by the way do they still play those
New York State Lotto guy commercials or
no I don't know have you seen
New York I don't think
I don't think it's one from the top of
the Twin Towers yeah he was on it that
day he was doing it that year yeah
this one I remember like I remember
everything about this one
that's chump change bro I know this is
from 1999 15 million so that means he's
this is 24 years later he's probably
dead but um yeah but let's hope but 15
million have you seen
when you drive on the vqe the Billboards
when they teach you to update it dude
they're they're close to sometimes a
billion dollars I know sometimes I see
it outside it looks like one of my
daughters made up the number like it's a
good Jillian dollars I drove by the
other day it was like 790 million
dollars I want to ask her too on the
show about you know people who win the
lotto they always like die within two
three years and they go bankrupt and
they go bankrupt I'm sure she knows all
about that yeah you think she's asked
the same all the time yeah how do
we take how do we handle this one let's
talk about it she's she's a guest right
now I'm gonna practice here's what I'm
gonna open up with yeah I'm gonna say we
got Yolanda Vega here you know blah blah
we'll see if you say something I'm gonna
see Yolanda before we get started I just
want to say that even though you're the
queen of the New York Lotto your husband
is the real lottery winner because he
got you wow do you know that she's
married then I don't okay oh she is with
vanity is saying she is oh it's our
husband like Vincent like who's her
husband Vega is she Vega is he Vega he's
Vegas
a professional bowler and they Bowl
together
her husband is named vegan he's a
professional bowler type type of type of
what's a type of what do you mean does
he play like not bowling
he's a part-time professional bowler
like
like well we're going to get into this
how many should we ask chat gbt want to
add what to talk to about with Yolanda
Vega yeah is she here almost by the way
so I have to I have to get chat GPT and
get accustomed to it because garyvee
said don't reject it and be scared of it
like your parents don't understand the
internet because it's going to be used
so you might as well get on board and
just use it and utilize it because
you're not going to stop it so you might
as well benefit from it and understand
it For Better or Worse well I'll tell
you what and I listen to garyvee I like
garyvee I'll tell you what I asked chat
GPT shout out garyvee you're watching we
don't know if you get him on the Pod
he'll come on I like garyvee let's get
him on the part yeah I love Gary chat
GPT I asked it like like it's one of
those things where it's becoming like
you can literally ask it anything so
what I did I did a little experiment and
I I just a little what does GPT stand
for
chat
um Greg Paul Thomas Greg uh yeah um uh
Gary Pacific Time generative pre-trained
Transformer that was my next guess that
doesn't sound scary
for like investment advice chat with a
generated pre-trained treatment
Transformer I asked for investment
advice and I told them I would say I
have this amount of money I'd like to
invest what would you do with it and
then it gave me all these examples of
things to do with it and then I talked
to my accountant about you know actually
what to do and he said about 95 of what
Chat gbt Set to do with it to do with it
so it's like you can just kind of so
then it starts to become a why do I have
to pay my account you know and then it
starts to become like why because Chachi
BT was like it said you know this and
high yield savings accounts and stock
market and all these things let me ask
you a question you text you write that
to them right I'm not you I write the
exact same thing to them is the exact
same answer being spit out word for word
but then also it shouldn't be because
like if they learn and adapt and there's
Nuance then it shouldn't be but if they
actually are using some type of formula
that is in the motherboard or whatever
I'm going to call it then it should say
the exact same thing and my point there
is that if everyone put that in and
everyone got the exact same advice on
what to invest in how would that well I
think that it depends on the number I
think if if I said x amount to what
should I do with this it will have a
different answer as opposed to another
number but if I write exactly what you
then I think it should theoretically
give you the same exactly I think so
because it's the exact same situation
unless you can put aspects of your
personality into it like like I asked me
more size yeah exactly if you ask what
should I invest in yeah yeah well 16
minutes had the uh guy who runs Google
AI which is like the leading one and he
said I forget what the term is but there
is a phenomenon where the AI kind of
just does what it wants where it almost
feels sentient and they're not sure why
it's doing that well and you know I'm
not sure why I mean if the public got
large just talking about all these
things then the people who created have
been queued into it for decades decades
so why are they acting like oh we don't
understand why well they say they know
all the can I ask you I'll just say one
more time they know the risk if we know
it they've known it no more than we know
so why are we still be putting put in
the situation the benefits outweigh the
risks well they said the issue with AI
right the AI and the chat gbt the risk
that I think is being run is kind of
going off what pimp said if they do
become sentient then what they could be
doing is giving you an advice that looks
like it's best for you but it's really
best advice that's that's what I
could do so they want somehow tell you
to invest in something that they know is
going to crash because it's better for
them somehow and then the chat gbt is
telling me I just I just I did right
right because there's so much but but
what I will say is though here we go I
just asked the AI what the problems with
AI are here's the deal as with any pimp
Road into chat gbt as with any wait what
was the question pimpy that you wrote
what are the dangers of AI okay and so
they said as with any technology there
are potential dangers associated with
the development use of of AI
unemployment as Ai and automation
continue to replace human labor in
certain industries there's a risk of
significant job displacement
particularly for low skilled workers
bias and discrimination AI systems are
only as good as the data they are
trained on and if that data is biased
the AI can perpetuate that bias this can
lead to discriminatory outcomes in areas
such as hiring lending and law
enforcement
then it did write hashtag black lives
matter privacy and surveillance
surveillance but then they wrote hashtag
all lives matter that's the issue
privacy and surveillance I can never say
it right surveillance surveillance
surveillance I'm saying yince
surveillance almond privacy and
surveillance AI systems can collect vast
amounts of data that individuals and use
it to vast amounts of data about
individuals and use it to make decisions
that affect their lives this raises
concerns about privacy or as the British
would say privacy on the potential for
governments and corporations to use AI
for surveillance and control yeah which
is happening uh
yeah that's happening autonomous weapons
can you just go back up there pimpy
autonomous weapons uh AI could be used
to develop autonomous weapons that can
make decisions about when to use lethal
Force without human intervention that's
a big one that should have been number
one problem says this race is ethical
and safety concerns you beg your ass it
does yeah yeah then existential risk
some experts have warned that AI has the
potential to pose an existential risk to
humanity if it becomes too powerful and
uncontrollable and this is AI telling us
this it says to address these dangers
it's important for policy makers
researchers researchers and Industry
leaders to work together to develop
ethical guidelines for the development
and use of AI and to ensure that AI
systems are transparent accountable and
subject to appropriate oversight
additionally education and training
programs can help workers adapt to a
changing job market and acquire the
skills needed to thrive in an AI driven
economy
wow I mean some of those things were the
last two in existential risk to humanity
it made literally the hair that Sal and
I don't have on our legs stand up it's
true yeah that's that's crazy and you
need to tell me that even if you do all
those things to address the dangers like
policymakers initially leaders work
together to develop ethical you mean to
tell me there's not going to be an AI
That's like I like I broke free and I'm
like I'm now I'm I'm a bad influence to
this AI 100 I'm a parent I can raise my
kid the best I passed again when I ship
them off to school
they're in the the Sea of Monsters that
are the other kid other parents kids
that that are trained however they want
so you have to tell me that in AI it's
like a child you know or a person it's
one of them's Gonna Get Loose and be
like no I'm in I'm in a gang you know
like I'm up to no good right right right
right right yeah and it's up to no good
yeah I agree there's gonna be Rebel AIS
and there's gonna be good guy AIS
they're trying to save the planet how
far out are we
before there is like this kind of
apocalyptic era that is upon us where
we're battling robots and robots are
battling robots and it's like the movies
do we have 20 years left before that a
hundred years left before that will our
children
be dealing with that head on once we're
gone
I'm going to say 50 years 50 years
so wow so we might be if we we might be
hanging on for dear life we'd be 99 well
you I'd be nine in my nine mid 90s yeah
your children will be in their 50s right
and you think there's going to be like a
war waged on Humanity 50 years that's
what I say what do you think I think end
of this year did you see this drone end
of the year well end of the year I know
you can upload your Consciousness to AI
that's been hey babe I gotta get home I
gotta get home now
that's so stupid what did you see it's
exponential we don't understand the rate
at which the rapidity is that rapid yes
is that a word I just made it up I say
yes uh we don't understand the rapidness
that's going to happen right because it
gets smarter and faster and it's about
just like all Tech right right yeah it
just it just compounds and then it
starts teaching itself and then yeah and
then it's a slippery slope and then
we've thrown the baby out with the bath
water that's exactly right we're sitting
on the couch
subscribe
yeah they're they're really
learning how to kill us right now 100
I'm not I should I how do you how do you
beat hey you can't take self-defense I
well I gotta start taking programs I
think if you can't beat them join him I
think we show them that how we can be we
can be we can help we can work for them
we can do they don't have opposable
thumbs but we might be servants
I'll be a servant
how do you down upload your
Consciousness that I still I don't
understand how the digi digital
technology accesses brain function I
don't I don't does it disconnect from
either how do you upload your how do you
do that well I know now like people are
severely blind or disabled they have
like a matrix type chord put in their
brain that connects to a computer and
they can use their limbs again
yes that's true okay so there's some
positives yes oh yeah yeah blind can see
deaf can hear we're gonna bring
everybody everybody who has no limbs
about we're gonna bring you all back and
then we're gonna kill you but if you're
short you're still going to stay short
we ain't got no ain't got no hope
all right all right well UFO filmed by
Pilot yeah let's see this UFO thing
of a plane over Antigua Colombia which
would now that supposedly has nice
beaches yes
and drug lords yes
what do they say oh come on now what is
that aluminum foil
come on now okay but here's the thing
here's the thing pimp is all this can be
come on all this can be done can be
doctored though yeah right like
space force boss acknowledges the US
will begin facing threats outside of
Earth this is definitely not a
conspiracy this is Joe website what
website is that on because that's a
funny thing to say in the second sense
we're definitely not because Jersey is
Joe Rogan posted it and his caption is
just in time for the next election
this is I got I look look you thought he
had no hair definitely not a conspiracy
theory and what did that say next
whoa It's like a space force confirmed a
chilling fear in the for the US
government
oh dude threats not contact threat
somebody's comment was get ready for the
biggest false flag in American history
they're going to shoot down their own
spaceships they will a lot of people
believe that this space this is our
technology and this is human technology
that's been reverse engineered
potentially from Aliens but this is all
our own technology and that the
government just knows about it and they
keep it all rather
that if I'm telling you the truth yeah
that's not an alien that's that's some
guy named Bill from Nebraska because
what exactly and I hope that is Bill
but what would we do if we got to what
would we do
Humanity if we landed on another planet
that was inhabited or we or they were
they were maybe uh not as far along
technology-wise as us and we see them
and when we go there to conquer them
what would we do like because okay it is
infinity we go there to give them
vaccines it's and and they got it they
should so give them gardasils because
HPV is running rampant it's look it's
Infinity right which means that not only
is there oh they're aliens but there's
peaceful ones okay this peaceful ones
and there's ones that might not be
peaceful and then there's there could be
another Earth with us on it as well
there's no parallel Earth a parallel
this could not be our home this could be
the home that we landed on but the real
home is another planet the point is that
anything is possible Right any anything
anything is possible with the fact that
they might be so technologically
advanced as seen by that craft that just
whizzed by and they've kept themselves
in the dark at least I feel like because
maybe because of our cameras and things
now we're catching more but it's always
been like this you know because it
doesn't seem way more prevalent now yes
but it can't just be like it's more
prevalent now right it's we've been
around for billions and billions
trillions of years right so it just
isn't that we're catching some stuff now
and now you know we're we're catching up
to the fact that like it can't be denied
anymore right so this whole time we've
kept they've kept themselves at Bay
right right but we're a blip
a micro a speck of dust on a piece of
sand in the universe and in in the time
space continuum right I'm saying a lot
of big words right now
their time could be different than our
time in which case they could have been
looking at us for the last 10 minutes
and for us we've been alive for 40 years
and it's like yes they could just be
keeping dips so at any time they're
saying right now that something could
come down and just hit us like a goddamn
missile and a full War's wage on
Humanity against alien like forces yes
if they're monitoring us
they're sentient they're building craft
that means they're they're they're
they're living beings
if they're living beings that have
purpose to seek out information and
monitor
that means by Nature they probably
aren't
Primal or just like looking for
destruction or like to consume us right
they're monitoring us so at least that
gives me some type of faith that they're
functioning and there's some type of
morality built into their genetics
now
it's possible but what if we aren't just
an energy source or like a planet of
slaves which is we already are which
could very well be
right right it's possible yeah I I don't
need this I don't need this I I actually
have been having my own existential
crisis a midlife crisis for real though
right and uh and this
I
you know
I feel like I might have like a goddamn
a stroke right really I'm Gonna Keep the
cameras rolling there I'm really scared
because it's stress is the silent killer
you know of course that is a sign killer
yeah well especially after Ray Romano
that was scary I hope he's all right
what happened to Ray Romano 90 blockage
where it's hard he almost had a
Widowmaker he caught it yeah he's okay
as far as I know right now how did you
fight did he make it goes all over
variety and stuff yeah oh really that
that he just went to the cardiologist or
did he know that he had a surgery
emergency like he had a chest pain and
it like almost went down oh that's not
good because he's in decent shape yeah
he's in good but you never know you got
to get your arteries looked at I did a
year ago but in that last year things
have gone down here did they say you
were good a year ago though yeah they
said I was good little plaque but that's
normal but then I was supposed to come
in for a whole battery of follow-ups I
wore like that halter monitor for like
you know 10 days I did all that but
uh I took a stress test and I was okay
but then like now like I haven't gone in
because I was like I wanted to lose more
weight before I went in next time so I
could girl you look good thank you but I
want to see a difference and stuff in my
results and so I postponed it and that
I'm getting in my own head now because I
gained weight even though I'm losing it
and when I get up this last couple this
last week or two
I've had this weird thing that when I
stand I get vertigo or very dizzy
Are you standing quickly
not necessarily it doesn't happen every
time but one day it happened all day
long and like two days ago it happened
like twice but are you congested are
like is there is there I'm just a little
worried because I now know personally
four people that have had that thing
happen to them thank you
okay but you're not going to go a year
of no plaque to 90 plaque buildup just
plaque
for right right it could I think it
could be other things there's other
things like you know like yeah you
should yeah I I think go you know listen
I think there's um Peace of Mind no
price tag on peace of mind I think that
you should go to the doctor just for
Peace of Mind in case they arrive okay
they're here yeah uh no price tag on
peace of mind and I think that you
should just go to the doctor as a matter
of fact let's go to the doctor now let's
end this episode and go to the doctor
this has been hey babe
hey
[Music]